i see the comment about money is what
matters when it comes to executives
i really do think understanding
executives is a fascinating
undertaking um
like just thinking about preparing
graphs that executives are going to
present or consume
i once told someone on my team long ago
like
he actually wrote a function called
execufy and like basically this needs to
take the graphs we have
and make it look like they were drawn
with a crayon
like simple big you know
and and that's the kind of thing that
often gets in the executive level
communications and then the question is
why because sometimes it seems like it
gets dumbed down the higher
it goes but executives are
generally very sharp people many of whom
have come from very detailed technical
backgrounds right so it's not about the
people it's about the
responsibilities they have and the
perspective they have and i think
really trying to understand that is
really helpful
in thinking about how to support them in
running the business and they do care
about money which can be frustrating but
is also really important if you
want to stay employed and work for a
company that
has money to spend on data scientists
and stays in business
so it's uh somebody has to care about
that and
we have to support them in some way in
doing their jobs
you